hierbei bild live jetzt aber zunächst
ins beet lagezentrum zu unserem bild
militärexperten julian julian rücken
gefallen
[Musik]
tag 37 von putins krieg gegen die
ukraine und wir haben dramatische
entwicklungen heute morgen offenbar hat
sich die russische armee von weiten
teilen der ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
und der vororte von kiew zurückgezogen
wir haben in den letzten stunden sowohl
eine bestätigung des gouverneurs von
kiew bekommen dass verschiedene vor ort
einfach verlassen wurden von den russen
die sich zurück nach belarus gezogen
haben sozusagen das nördliche
nachbarland der ukraine und auch der
gouverneur von cerny lief einer region
östlich von kiew im norden ukraine hat
bestätigt dass die russischen truppen
dort auf dem rückmarsch sind wir gucken
uns das ganze erstmal auf der karte an
schon vor drei tagen hatten die ukrainer
den vorort ihnen hier zurückerobert
versuch das mal hier so zu kennzeichnen
und ihn einer der wichtigsten vororte
der nächste vor ort an kiew der
überhaupt eingenommen wurde und wir
haben jetzt die information und auch die
bestätigung aus sowohl frei verfügbaren
quellen als auch leuten mit denen wir
gesprochen haben als auch den
gouverneuren dass auch butscher und
horst hummel inklusive des
militärflughafens und die gesamte region
weiter in richtung norden ich zeige dass
man hier auf dieser karte
heute morgen von den russischen truppen
verlassen wurde und zwar nicht friedlich
sondern unter schweren ukrainischen
feuer hier noch mal zu sehen diese rote
gebiete sind die die bisher gesetzt
wurden von musikgruppen cerny hierfür
auf der seite auch dort haben wir
extreme starke ukrainische gegen
offensiven seit mehreren tagen die
allein gestern 40 orte dort eingenommen
haben auch dort heute morgen der bericht
dass sich die russen hier zurückziehen
wir wollen uns das ganze mal angucken
wie das aussieht es gibt seit gestern
drohnen aufnahmen aus rostock wir
erinnern uns vielleicht rostow mill der
flughafen etwa 20 kilometer nördlich von
kiew wo die russen bereits am ersten
morgen der inversion gelandet sind wo es
diese luft lande operation gab und ein
hubschrauber dort menschen abgesetzt
haben russische fallschirmspringer von
dort aus sind sie richtung vier
vorgestossen und haben die vororte
butscher und ihn dann weitestgehend
zerstört und besetzt wir gucken uns das
mal an der flughafen von haus thome
da wo die großen antonows gebaut wurden
hier übrigens mit einem hangar wo noch
mal da das wrack dieser dieser anton auf
205 dem einzigen größte flugzeug der
welt was dort zerstört wurde zu sehen
ist aber eben auch der rest von des
flughafens hier steht noch eine boeing
beispielsweise völlig leer hier waren
die russen das war ihr sprungbrett nach
44 haben sie ihren nach studien
transportiert mit hubschraubern von hier
aus haben sie versucht iranischen
hauptstadt einzunehmen all das und diese
aufnahmen sind von gestern ist völlig
verlassen hier gibt es keine russen mehr
und wir haben heute morgen eben die
bestätigung dass hier auch aus weiteren
wichtigen städten unter anderem ivancan
örtlich von kiew aber auch der zone rund
um tschernobyl also eine grenze zwischen
ukraine und belarus geflüchtet sind sie
sind also haben diese einfach verlassen
über nacht seit zwei oder drei tagen
ziehen sie heimlich ab gestern und heute
nacht im großen stil und es gibt auch
ausnahmen wie viele russische panzer und
russische truppen noch auf diesen
rückzugs weg dort zerstört wurden von
afghanischen kräften also wirklich sehr
faszinierende aufgaben hier unten sieht
man noch mal diese dieses größte
flugzeug der welt vielleicht kann man da
einmal rauf blenden wir sehen hier vorne
die nase wenn man so möchte also dass
und ein cockpit sozusagen und hier die
drei triebwerke auf der einen seite drei
triebwerke nebeneinander diese flugzeug
hatte sechs triebwerke eines der größten
er über das größte der welt wie gesagt
völlig zerstört worden hier bei den
kämpfen und hier vor waren sozusagen die
russen stationiert wir sehen hier auch
überall noch die russischen fahrzeuge
die verbrannt sind die dort stehen die
wurden angegriffen von ukrainischen
truppen
mittlerweile gibt es dort keine busse
mehr also wirklich eine dramatische
entwicklung russland zieht seine truppen
vor kiew ab gibt sich offenbar für den
moment geschlagen um die köpfe die
schlacht um kiew und nicht bloß dort
gibt es dramatische ereignisse wir
wollen uns mal angucken wie diese gegen
offensiven weiterhin funktionieren wir
haben die lage in cerny lief
beispielsweise hatte ich gerade von
gesprochen das sind aufnahmen von
gestern auch hier die russische armee
geschlagen von ukrainischen verbänden
wir sehen hier zerstörte panzer der
russischen armee und dazwischen
ukrainische soldaten die hier die
größeren straßen kontrollieren wie
gesagt bis zu 40 orte an ein wurden hier
gestern zurückerobert bevor sich
offenbar über nacht dann die restlichen
russen zurückgezogen haben aus diesem
teil der ukraine
also wieder das gleiche bild was wir was
wir immer gesehen haben leichte
ukrainische einheiten die tatsächlich zu
fuss ebene
gehen große zerstörte russische panzer
auf der anderen seite schiebt das x ein
bisschen vor
hier geht es dann weiter russische
panzer auf der anderen seite die auf den
großen straßen ja wenn man sie möchte
gefangen waren die also einfach nicht
davon wegkommen und einfach keine
möglichkeit hatten jenseits der strafen
vorzurücken und sofern insofern für die
ukrainer hier leichte beute waren die im
wald von links und rechts diese konvois
angegriffen haben und dann auch zerstört
haben mit ihren panzerabwehrwaffen viele
davon aus dem westen und viele davon
dass muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
werden nicht gezeigt in diesem videos
weil die ukrainer natürlich nicht auch
den russen zeigen wollen was genau sie
hier haben wir gucken uns auch noch die
lage in karachi van auch dort eine
erfolgreiche ukrainische gegenoffensive
das ist die autobahn südlich von prag fg
gestern hier
vorgestern schon zurückerobert wurde und
gestern gezeigt wurde und wir sehen
hoffentlich gleich noch mal dass das
hier das da sehen wir es dass hier
russische panzer abgeschleppt werden ein
russischer panzer mit einer ukrainischen
flagge obendrauf schlägt einen anderen
russischen panzer ohne ukrainische
flagge ab beide panzer noch vor kurzem
im dienste von putins militär jetzt teil
der ukrainischen armee also auch hier
die ukraine auf dem rückzug zurück in
die russen auf dem rückzug natürlich und
eine eine situation die sich tatsächlich
im norden des landes und im osten des
landes wieder zeigt lediglich im donbass
lediglich
im osten des landes wir sehen uns hier
in der region lugano zurück
daneben in den regionen lukas und
donetsk an wir weiterhin russische
vorstöße und die stadt mario pohl das
wissen wir steht leider sehr kurz vor
dem fall an die russische armee und dass
die lage zu diesem zeitpunkt
unser bild militärs